На цій непримітній вулиці в містечку Тросдорф поблизу Бонна знаходиться компанія Dynitec,
яка вже понад століття виробляє вибухові речовини для ракет та артилерійських снарядів.
Це підприємство належить оборонній компанії Diehl Defence.
На тлі дискусії про розширення виробництва озброєння у Німеччині
Diehl Defence планувала значно збільшити свої потужності в Тросдорфі.
Проте міська рада поставила хрест на цих планах.
Причина: у разі розширення виробництва вибухівки необхідно буде збільшити безпечну зону навколо самого заводу,
і на цій території не можна буде будувати ні житло, ні інші підприємства.
Варто також зазначити, що за таке рішення голосували, зокрема, і християнські демократи, і зелені у місцевій раді.
Хоча політики від цих партій на федеральному рівні неодноразово закликали канцлера Німеччини
збільшити військову допомогу для України.
Для Diehl Defence рішення міської ради Тросдорфа стало проблемою.
Ця компанія відома завдяки своїй новітній системі ППО Iris-T.
Уряд Німеччини передав Україні вже три такі комплекси, останній - наприкінці листопада минулого року.
І, як повідомляється, Київ вкрай гостро потребує саме ракет для Iris-T.
Для нарощування виробництва таких снарядів компанії Diehl Defence потрібно було розширення заводу в Тросдорфі.
Водночас, крім ракет і артилерійських снарядів, є і величезний попит на гранати.
Нещодавно міністр оборони Німеччини Борис Пісторіус був змушений визнати,
що ЄС не зможе виконати свою обіцянку поставити Україні мільйон артилерійських снарядів до весни.
Одна з причин: нестача виробничих потужностей.
Про це напередодні говорили і представники німецького уряду.
Що стосується ППО, то зараз ми зробили все можливе,
і ми постійно переглядаємо наші запаси.
Чинником, що обмежує на цей момент, є виробництво.
Ми ведемо переговори з іноземними урядами про те,
щоб вони відкликали свої замовлення на користь України,
їхні замовлення будуть виконані в більш пізні терміни.
Ми також докладаємо всіх зусиль, щоб продовжити організацію постачання артилерійських боєприпасів тощо,
щоб Україна могла захистити себе від цих атак.
Останніми часом у Німеччині знову посилилися заклики збільшити військову допомогу Україні.
Голова комітету Бундестагу з оборони Марі-Агнес Штрак-Циммерман
вимагає від уряду Олафа Шольца схвалити постачання Україні
далекобійних крилатих ракет Taurus.
Заохочують до цього й однопартійці канцлера.
Я можу сказати вам одне
- і такої думки дотримуються багато колег з бундестагу
- що в сьогоднішній складній ситуації крилаті ракети
могли б надати допомогу, щоб стабілізувати ситуацію на фронті.
Це дуже складна ситуація. Ідеться про те,
щоб дати Україні можливість боротися далі.
Адже поки що ми ще далекі від перемоги України над Росією.
Таурус – високоточні крилаті ракети.
Вони схожі на Storm Shadow та Scalp, які Україні вже поставили Великобританія та Франція.
Якщо дальність перших обмежена 250-270 кілометрами,
то Таурус може вражати цілі в радіусі п'ятисот кілометрів.
Це і стало каменем спотикання уряду Шольца.
Питання постачання крилатих ракет має деякі…
не хочу сказати проблеми, але аспекти, які треба враховувати.
Наприклад, де вони будуть використовуватись,
це військове питання. Німеччина не хоче стати стороною конфлікту.
Я вважаю, що це включає те, що ракети не повинні
бути використані для цілей на території Росії.
І це ми обговорювали з українськими колегами.
І домовились про це.
Тому експерти вважають, що побоювання Німеччини перебільшені.
За цим стоїть страх, що крилаті ракети
будуть використовувати по цілях на території Росії.
Була навіть пропозиція знизити дальність цих ракет.
Але це не розумно.
Якщо їх правильно налаштувати та навчити персонал,
то можна виключити випадкові цілі.
Замість того, щоб міркувати про складнощі тут у Німеччині,
можна використати цей час і почати навчати українських солдатів.
За словами експертів, зараз таких ракет на озброєнні бундесверу
за офіційною статистикою шістсот штук.
Але не всі готові до застосування.
До того ж, попереджають аналітики, якщо частину з них передати Україні,
то потрібно переконатися, що й бундесвер забезпечений та готовий до бою та оборони.
І тут знову ж таки постає питання виробництва та нарощування потужностей.
Чи потрібно один якийсь вид озброєння поставити Україні,
чи інший, чи взагалі нічого не постачати.
У багатьох випадках у Німеччині обговорюються якісь символічні форми.
Але такі розмови недоречні.
Потрібно все постачати. Але у такій кількості, щоб самим не залишитися без зброї.
Це означає, зрештою, необхідно самим інвестувати у озброєння.
І для наших потреб, і для потреб України.
І це має відбуватися швидше.
Представники оборонки скаржаться на відсутність чіткого планування у влади.
У німецькому міністерстві оборони звинувачують ВПК у тому,
що він недостатньо швидко нарощує виробничі потужності попри на замовлення,
що добре фінансуються.
У результаті сторонам не виходить зрушити з мертвої точки
і знайти рішення, яке влаштувало б і політиків,
і оборонну промисловість.
А ще часом в оборонну суперечку вступає і німецька муніципальна влада,
як це стало зрозуміло у випадку із заводом у Тросдорфі